les travaux parlementaires avaient pris
fin en juin sur le thème de
l'immigration
deux mois plus tard ils reprennent sur
le même sujet ainsi nous souhaitons
favoriser la sélection des personnes
migrantes qui peu après les avoir
diminué à 40000 l'an dernier la carte
propose maintenant de réaugmenter les
seuils d'immigration la hausse proposée
et graduelle environ 43 mail immigrants
seraient et demi en 2020 46000 en 2021
et 51000 en 2022 mais tout peut encore
changer prévient le ministre
c'est un document de consultation ont
conçu le cette semaine l'idée du
gouvernement du québec sera déposé avant
le 1er novembre mais entre temps en mode
écoute
les choses semblaient pourtant beaucoup
plus simple en campagne électorale
moi je le dis leur quarante mille
immigrés dont seul et jacques pour moi
1er octobre parce qu'ils veulent 40 mais
les migrants mais le gouvernement est
maintenant difficile à suivre dénonce
les partis d'opposition aujourd'hui il
propose de revenir au seuil avant
l'éviction du gouvernement caquistes
donc un gouvernement qui joue carrément
avec l'immigration aux apprentis y avait
un objectif électoraliste qu'on allait
prendre un peu de recul
en prenant ce peu de recul que j'étais
en mesure de réparer le sann immigration
et on et étape par étape de façon
ordonnée
entre-temps employeurs et entreprises
accentuent la pression mais québec
devrait accueillir au moins soixante
mille migrants cette année distille sans
quoi les difficultés de recrutement
s'accentueront pas le problème qu'on est
en rareté mais dont on n'est pas sûr +9
déjà aujourd'hui au moment où je vous
parle
ils sont dix-huit mille postes ouverts
au québec l'opposition officielle
partage ces inquiétudes et demande au
gouvernement de refaire ses devoirs
le nombre actuel tel que premier par la
cat ne répond pas à notre besoin ne
répond en aucun cas à la demande de
l'ensemble des entreprises et
entrepreneurs du québec
mais attention à ne pas réduire
l'immigration à une simple question
économique a prévenu le premier groupe
invité à présenter un mémoire il c'est
correct d'aller chercher de la valeur
mais il n'ya pas que ça il ya des femmes
et il ya des femmes des enfants
l'intégration s'est
bi directionnelle une trentaine
d'organismes et d'individus auront
l'occasion de s'exprimer d'ici la fin de
la semaine
jusqu'ici la question de l'immigration
s'est surtout posé en termes économiques
mais des groupes en temps de faire
valoir d'autres préoccupations comme la
pérennité de la langue française le
poids démographique du québec au sein du
canada ou encore les obligations
humanitaires du québec ici hugo lavallée
radio canada québec